senator elizabeth warren just released a
campaign ad
disguised as a dna test or maybe
it was a dna test disguised as a
campaign ad in it she ladles her dna
results with somber relatives and
music and even includes me i'm touched
but that happens every time i take the
subway
i hear some of your republicans i am a
republican registered
yes what do you think of him calling her
pocahontas
well i think it's ridiculous i think
it's silly
does warren translate into cherokee as
spreading bull
i think we did find five segments of
native american ancestry with very high
confidence
where we believe the error rate is less
than one in a thousand now
the president likes to call my mom a
liar
what do the facts say the facts suggest
that you absolutely have a native
american ancestor in your pedigree
[Music]
so her native american ancestry may date
back six to ten generations
she's potentially one one thousand
and twenty fourth indian which is zero
point
zero nine percent using such standards
i'm asian which is why i can't get into
harvard
[Laughter]
so no wonder she had to rely on
sentiment and victimhood but this
really isn't about history but her story
and fixing it because it's a mess
did she or did she not list herself as a
minority in law school directories when
it suited her
then removed it when it didn't it's not
about her background it's about cheating
she's a white woman of vast european
ancestry who went to the buffet of
identity politics and took
seconds then thirds warren is native
american
because she said so she wins the 2018
rachel dolezal award
so if we all do the same test as hers
and find similar percentages
aren't we also eligible to claim the
experiences of an oppressed group and
their past grievances
too her results now become the standard
for anyone choosing a past
that offers an edge who can now skip
ahead in admissions or
jobs in places where diversity trumps
experience
and so dna tests become the new
affirmative action
but at whose expense maybe no one
because if we're all a little oppressed
we're all good goodbye identity politics
if everyone is a minority
then nobody is the silver lining there
is a silver lining i think she did
the nation of service we are now all
native american this is an interesting
fact from uh
michael aaron uh eris what's his name
erin's from a gop spokesman
danny you use the new york times
sourcing the average european american
is 0.18 so the average european
american is actually more native
american than she is
wow did this backfire i think a little
bit it is interesting that a lot of
the media were treating this as her
response to trump but remember she's
going to have to get through a
democratic primary and i
imagine that if if if it maybe got down
to the top ten
yes that her opponents were going to use
this donald trump wasn't going to have
to do anything
so i think she's overreacting a little
bit to your point she has never
actually had answered this question why
did she list
not list it when she was applying to
lower tier schools
only listed it when she applied to the
higher tier schools
and then did not list it after she had
tenure
that is even if you are native american
why did you list it
when you only thought it was going to
help you get an edge good point
juan do you think that this is about
trump or is it about the uh
the people she's gonna have to face
before trump no i think it was about the
effectiveness of the trump attack
calling her pocahontas and
ridiculing her in that way and so i
think she wanted to respond
and i and now i think it's like jujitsu
she thinks that she has put the pressure
on trump uh the key thing here for me
is that when the papers then
asked the folks at harvard did you in
fact consider this when you hire they
said no
when they i looked at the university of
pennsylvania in fact i think they said
at the university of pennsylvania they
filled out a form explaining
why they hired a white woman over
minority candidates
so the whole basis the foundation of the
trump attack was
hey you use this to get ahead falsely
right and it turns out that's not true
in addition to which she has some native
american ancestry
i i would disagree with you on and
you're shocked but in 1997 fordham
university
the law review described warren as
harvard
law school's first woman of color
so they had that cemented in their
legacy the
funny thing about this today though for
me was looking at the way that the media
reacted to this
before really looking at the study and
going through the numbers it was
warren verifies that she's native
american and the boston globe
goes through a series of corrections
because first they were saying it was
132nd
then they go all the way to correcting
it due to a math error and it turns out
to be
1 and 1024 and so would you keep going
down the line
of the impossibilities of the point that
you just brought up greg in the sense
that
she is less native american than the
majority of
americans so do you guys think do you
guys think that uh she's owed a million
bucks by trump i
i would actually say well pete i i would
say i think it would be good for donald
trump to to donate that money
write it off yeah and then thank her
thank her for saying
she points out everyone in america is a
native american
she's done a service thank you for doing
the work for me yes
yeah pay the money he's got the money do
it why not yeah yeah
and i i can see the campaign t-shirts
now uh you know wearing it
i'm black i'm hispanic i'm
jewish i'm whatever and on the back you
just like .09
1.3 2.4 whatever you want to be to your
point
it is exploiting minority status she did
it she did it time and time again
and what the president did was
devastatingly
lay out how she used it for her own
advantage
continues to unit for use it for her
advantage and now
she's trying she thinks she's getting
ahead of it no no no no she's creating
more of a problem for herself
it's just she can't get past it this
will make it worse also she just has
terrible
political timing right um so
we're 22 days to the midterm elections
the democrats are losing ground with
many republicans but they still have an
edge especially in the house not in the
senate
but they're losing ground but they have
all this money so they have all this
they could have used all day today all
this week
they could have been talking about that
but instead she had to release this
today why couldn't you do this a day
after the election
they think it's great i don't think they
get it out before the midterm i don't
think so
most of the democrats that like jim
messina for example who was obama's
communications person was like pulling
his hair out
saying why would you do this today it
doesn't it doesn't help any of the
democrats that are on the phone
what i'm saying is that in this and the
story
about the dna test came the day after a
washington post story about
how great she's been to all these
democratic candidates once they win
their primaries
she's there with a phone call of support
with money so that was basically saying
wow like she's doing a lot to try to
build up a lot of support within the
party and then she does this
well and the thing is too is she's
having serious problems on the left and
she thinks that this is going to help
her
by claiming with the unsubstantiated
evidence really
that she has minority status on the left
that's a problem with the
intersectionality argument the white
woman
trying to represent minorities arguments
especially when she's up against people
like cory booker and kamala harris
and then on the right people are saying
look you're a liar you exploited this to
get ahead despite you claiming that you
didn't there's all this evidence and a
number of law reviews saying that you
were chosen essentially or at least
stouted on the fact that your name was
listed as a minority as a professor
before you got to harvard law
so she has problems on both sides of the
aisle both in a primary for 2020
and in a general election well i must
tell you that on the demo from a
democrat's perspective i don't think
you're right but it's interesting to
listen to how you republicans are
responding because i was quoting jim
messina because i don't
know messina was saying the timing might
be an issue but not all of this kind of
piling on i mean i think it's
interesting to my mind what comes out
is here's another trump fallacy oh
pocahontas he likes to ridicule people
so one percent constitutes your ethnic
background i don't care what it is the
fact is
because her family history her family
history was that her great
grandmother was saying hold on you're
saying great great indian great great
great and she lied about it thinking
about the great grandmother who told her
this
i don't need to tell a photographer and
then pretend like it's true
well i don't know i'm just saying that
was her family's story she didn't know
obviously that's why she had to have the
test
sure look my 23andme to your point
has me at two percent native american
which is actually more than her
so i'm welcome welcoming her to my
family but it is
but to the point and it's actually a
bigger a bigger point
is this the next step in in affirmative
action dna testing
so that every single person when you're
applying for college
you get the 23 and me or i don't yeah
you can't you don't just get to check
the box you have to send in your results
you have to send in your results yes
scary i'm one percent albanian remember
that from the 23. that's
true i was too scared i was actually
sitting at my desk last night about to
do that test because i've been sitting
there for a year
and i got freaked out reading the terms
of service and they put it back and it's
back on the desk
you know i think you know we always talk
about identity politics at the table
but if you are applying you really want
to be white upper class let me tell you
well that would
maybe not have gotten into the harvard
if you know but that's not true harvard
says that's not true and by the way
well no but i'm saying university of
pennsylvania harvard say the same thing
and then you said oh but fordham listed
said
they did well guess what this we think
this woman made it but it didn't
impact her ability to get it
harvard really thinks in this asian in
this asian discrimination case yeah
we're going to see
how they treat people for real because
we're going to be covering that i think
walter wall
aren't we going to be amazing all right